my name is sh
in this Ramadan I'm going to be sharing with you everything possible that we can cover
in these next 30 days on the subject matter of Dua it's one of the most
important subjects in Islam Allah subhana wa tala has literally linked Dua and made it synonymous
with worship the act of Dua which is supplication inside or outside of prayer asking Allah
for our needs
is a subject that encapsulates so much about our belief in Allah and our submission to
him and the first thing we're going to talk about are the three greatest misconceptions that
people have on this subject of
Supplication
now the first thing and you may know a lot of people who have this misconception
is they imagine that Dua is only for major things many people have this idea that
Dua is only for when you have cancer when you're about to die if you've had
a car accident and many people will not ever ever make Dua until something terrible happens
the companions of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam used to make Dua and ask Allah for
help even when they go to the market to buy sandals one night Prophet ibraim
who used to
receive Revelation from Allah all the time he was eating his dinner late he heard a
voice saying oh ibraim why are you eating your dinner so late tonight this is not
your normal he said oh Allah I went from house to house to try to sell
something to borrow money to borrow food and I couldn't find anyone to interact with or
to trade with until late at night so Allah T responded to him and he said
is this what a friend does with a friend a
because KH means someone very close to you ibraim you don't ask me what kind of
KH am I to you and you to me when you're hungry and you ever asked
me so Prophet ibraim said oh Allah
should I ask you even for my dinner Allah T responded to him oh ibraim my
if you need some salt ask me so Allah T is telling us
that Dua is for every little need that you have and you shouldn't imagine
that Dua is only for major things even a prick you touch the thorn and you
want that pain to go away that's a dire need so a dire need
in the field and the context of Supplication and prayer to Allah the bar is very
low unlike the dire need in Islamic law which is life and death so when you
hear about supplicating to Allah when you're in a state of dire need don't imagine it's
the dire need of the Sacred law which is the dire need that makes Haram
life and death or life and limb as they say sometimes that I could lose a
limb I could go blind or I could lose my arm or I can go to
jail but in this realm of Dua it's much lower than that furthermore dire need is
anything that you want not just need many people also Imagine Dua is only for like
negative causes I have a sickness I had a car crash I have poverty rather than
for positive causes that I want to add something to my life I want to make
something better these are also classified as needs because you want them your heart is unsettled
without them in conclusion Dua is not just for major needs Dua should not only be
at the side of a hospital bed
or at a funeral Dua is for every big and every small negative or positive if
you like the video that you just watched subscribe to our YouTube channel click the bell
for notifications and if you really liked what you just saw support us at
patreon.com